welcome back we're here with Tabitha
Brown who I love so much and in honor of
your inspirational new book that I
cannot get enough of cuz it's so full of
prompts and ideas and so many takeaways
thank you oh God I love it so much well
we thought we'd take a few questions
from the audience with a round of Drew
and a but Tabitha will be answering
because as far as I'm concerned I've
heard all my Spiel I want to hear yours
all right so first up is guel where are
you gu oh hi gu how are
hi Drew hi Tabitha um I'm single just
like
you um I've never joined a dating app
before so what advice would you give for
joining a dating app how long have you
been
single like three years three years you
said it like 30 years is just three girl
it's just three years it's all right how
long you been single seven okay it's all
right um almost eight it's all right
well eight is the number of new
beginnings seven is the year of
completion
but is New Beginnings
so oh my gosh that's right that's
right got something happen is the magic
number they say so maybe good things are
going to happen for both of us I hope so
gu would you be willing to get on a
dating app and try
it yes all right come on is there
anything we can do for Foster this uh
move um we can start with a profile pick
let's do it oh right I say do that now
can can we be in the profile can
we it would make a great story you find
my husband I'll
tell you get I mean I don't know about
you but I think Tabatha really brings
your cred up right too so you know
yes
pick
her
you all right well now Ross's gonna do a
first um rossie where are
you
[Applause]
Ronnie hello hi
[Music]
hi than it looks hi why do you look so
good in a wet suit I've never been in a
wet suit before I don't know oh it was
so hard to get on I can't even tell you
hi no you really you look like it's
weird you look sexy and I you're like oh
my God Drew turned on by me look at this
well if only you know there is a reason
I I'm attracted to gay men it's so it's
so compatible we it just this is the
life I'm looking for but you it might
also be why you single cuz they're not
looking for you you might have just
solved it you know they not look for
taba you're absolutely right once again
they not for you all well this is your
first this is about you I'm going to
shut up so I'm going to jump in that ice
cold tub of water
okay okay you got that the fli okay like
how cold is
it oh my God that is so
C
that's
okay all right all
right
[Applause]
I will you so hard oh
my so we got to calm down how are you
I'm not doing great and relax H how is
it is it as bad as you thought it was
going to be or just 1% better I'm not
warming up to this at all but you're in
it you're doing it you are doing it feel
like I'm in a martini shaker okay okay
guess what in honor of Tabitha did you
do a thing I did a thing I
did wait by the way did you know also
the only way you're allowed out of that
tub the only way you're allowed out of
that tub is if you come clean about
something oh my God you can't get out
until you come clean about something um
okay um I've never told you this get
those legs back in there I've never told
you this what I waited for the right
time I don't know if this is it I love
you so much I've never seen
ET oh H well can I get out now you get
out now oh my god
did guess what you're about to do two
things cuz I want you to watch ET cuz
it's so good we want to watch watch it
together with the girls oh my
God you know what else I would love what
if you got in the no I'm kidding I'm not
doing I'm not going to do it I'm not
going to do it I'm not I would have done
it well Ross um I do have something
everybody in the audience is going to go
home with Tabitha's new book I did a new
thing wherever book are sld and everyone
gets to try a new
thing and and for all of us here who are
becoming friends and family and I really
mean that I will start this by doing a
new thing myself and if you'll do a
video and tag our show and do a new
thing too we can all do this in honor of
Tabitha's new
book all right we'll be right back don't
go
[Applause]
anywhere